welcome to Hannity all right tonight the
Democrat it's psychotic mindless
antitrump rage psychosis sinking to new
depths of depravity what was a
disastrous day for them as they pursue
Trump every second minute hour of every
day they are hurting the country they
are ripping this country apart
just for cheap baseless a political hit
job and after today's total BS if you
want to call it impeachment hearing on
Capitol Hill your blood should be
boiling but you have the answer in 335
days now instead of presenting actual
evidence Democrats thought we the stupid
smelly from supporting won't Walmart
shoppers that believe in God of America
need to be educated on the virtues of
impeachment so to educate we the people
the masses of people's they hauled in
three hyper-partisan far left holier
than now sanctimonious self-righteous
ivory tower law school professors to
teach us about the Constitution the
really good news tonight is to their
credit Republicans they were united they
fought back in a big and effective way
congressman Collins Jordan and the up
Matt Gaetz rock stars today along with
others and the GOP sole witness
constitutional scholar Jonathan Turley
he literally a Democrat didn't vote for
Trump voted for Obama also voted for the
Clintons ran circles around the liberal
professor sitting next to him
maybe that's because Turley's judgment
wasn't clouded by as he discussed rage
and hate and hysteria the Democrats
three witnesses on the other hand they
were clearly suffering from stage four a
case of massive Trump derangement
syndrome disconnected from all truth and
reality un c-- law professor this guy
Michael Gerhart worked for the Clintons
in their administration Al Gore's Senate
campaign a month ago he authored an
impassioned piece in the Atlantic
praising the ship show and his fellow
witnesses Javed law professor Noah
Feldman oh he's been looking for ways to
impeach Trump since 2017 in just a few
weeks after the president was sworn in
that guy
Feldman argued the
President Trump could be impeached or
his use of the term fake news I kid you
not there it is the perfect ivory tower
law professor seemingly hating free
speech due process presumption of
innocence and certainly cannot be
counted on to seek truth and justice
days later he claimed that the president
could be impeached because of an ad for
mar-a-lago and in March 2017 not to be
outdone Feldman wrote the Trump could be
impeached over his tweets about
wiretapping believe it or not Feldman's
deranged anti-trump bias just pales in
comparison to the Democrats third
witness yes
ivory tower Stanford Law Professor
Pamela Carlin is her name a devout
liberal actually too extreme for even
the Obama administration on to Eric
Holder donated thousands of dollars to
Hillary Clinton Barack Obama and in June
Wow who's she supporting for president
another thousand dollars to that
socialist yes ninety four trillion
dollar new Green Deal Medicare for all
fifty two trillion dollar Elizabeth
Warren and Carlin once appeared at a
podcast called versus Trump where she
trashed conservatives are insane rage
against all things Trump is so extreme
she refuses to even walk on the same
side of the street not making this up as
a trump hotel we've got the videotape
let's go to it I came in from the
airport yesterday and I got off the bus
from Dulles down at L'Enfant Plaza and I
walked up to that Ellen as I was walking
past what used to be the old post office
building and is now that Trump Hotel
that's it which it's across the street
of course never Wow another great
witness imagine carrying around that
much hatred that much resentment and
anger every day of your life pretty sad
pretty pathetic not good for the country
and frankly House Democrats they look
really really stupid I didn't think you
could outdo the ship show but they did
for hauling that psychotic individual
before Congress
case in point at today's hearings she
made a pretty disgusting repulsive joke
about the president and Melania Trump
year-old son watch this what comparisons
professor Carlin can we make between
Kings that the framers were afraid of
and the president's conduct today so
Kings could do no wrong because the
Kings word was law and contrary to what
President Trump has said article two
does not have give him the power to do
anything he wants and I'll just give you
one example that shows you the
difference between him and a king which
is the Constitution says there can be no
titles of nobility so while the
president can name his son Baron he
can't make him a baron now shortly after
the professor's disgraceful remarks the
First Lady Melania Trump rightly
responded with this powerful statement
quote a minor child deserves privacy and
should be kept out of politics
Pamela Carlin you should be ashamed of
you're very angry and obviously by his
public pandering and using a child to do
it during the hearing congressman Matt
Gaetz on his game also rebuked the
Democrat star witness right to her face
great moment for him take a look when
you talk about how liberals want to be
around each other in cluster and
conservatives don't want to be around
each other and so they have to spread
out it makes people you may not see this
from you know like the ivory towers of
your law school but it makes actual
people in this country we're gonna like
this man I'll get to interupt me on this
time now let me also suggest that when
you invoke the president's son's name
here when you try to make a little joke
out of referencing Barron Trump that
does not lend credibility to your
argument it makes you look mean it makes
you look like you're attacking someone's
family the minor child of the President
of the United States he word minor child
and professor issued just a half-hearted
phony apology but make no mistake that
it was an unmitigated disaster for the
Democrats this was worse than the ship
show how stupid do they think we are
they bring in three liberal
mean-spirited Trump hating professors
who live and work in their ivory towers
all trying to convince us that the
president's alleged wrongdoing with no
evidence not only do they have a clear
established political bias and hatred
but they witnessed nothing the only fact
witness in this entire
shrade we've only had one testified that
when he asked President Trump what he
wanted from Ukraine nothing no quid pro
quo just be honourable that's it those
professors opinions they don't matter
conjecture that doesn't matter opinion
witnesses they don't matter none of
their testimony matters because the
facts have not changed that as
Congressman Jim Jordan often points out
the facts are not on the Democratic the
Democrat side or the mob and the media
side take a look just cut to the chase
the reason it's been unfair scuzz the
facts aren't on their side the facts are
on the president's side four key facts
will not change have not changed will
never change we have the transcript
there was no quid pro quo in the
transcript the two guys on the call
President Trump and President Solinsky
both said no pressure no pushing no quid
pro quo the Ukrainians third didn't know
that the aid was held up at the time of
the phone call and fourth and most
important Ukrainians never started never
promised to start and never announced an
investigation in the time that the aid
was paused never once those four facts
as congressman Jordan always says they
never change irrefutable facts on the
Trump Ukraine phone call in question aid
was never ever once discussed now add to
that five subsequent high-level meetings
including one with the vice president of
the United States and the president of
Ukraine all the five with the president
of Ukraine this is after the phone call
aid was never tied to anything at any
one of the five meetings never brought
up in any way and by the way so what did
you crane do before Trump released the
money nothing and they still got the
money that would be no quid pro or quo
like Joe and don't forget the
transcripts of the president's phone
call wit Solinsky shows remember he
talks about and want you to do us a
favor us plural and he mentioned that he
said do us a favor
he was talking about both countries the
2016 election interference by Ukraine it
had nothing to do with the Biden's and
by the way everyone keeps saying
conservatives believe that Ukraine was
responsible
for election interference in 2016 and
not Russia it's a conspiracy theory no
I've never said that we pointed out many
times on this program Russia is a
hostile regime led by a hostile actor
Vladimir Putin who we're not going to
have more flexibility with ever I have
zero doubt they meddled in the 2016
elections I'm certain they did
Devin Nunez was warning Obama in 2014 it
would happen but they did nothing and by
the way yeah look at the dirty Russian
dossier that Hillary bought and paid for
according to the New York Times very
late in the game likely Russian
disinformation from the beginning and
yes Russia interfered in our 2016
elections they have done it before
they're going to try and do it again
every indication is also though separate
and apart Ukraine interfered in our
elections as well and I have no doubt
others the January 11 2017 political
reports in detail Ukrainian Court also
ruled that their country interfered in
our 2016 elections to help Hillary it's
not mutually exclusive
how many countries hacked in a Hillary
server they probably interfered also and
look at this on the very same phone call
the president expressed concern the
brand new president of Ukraine was
surrounding himself with some of the
same corrupt officials as the last
president that's not smart you better
not do that president has reiterated
many times he doesn't want to give away
hundreds of millions of taxpayer dollars
without knowing who it is going to and
how it is going to be used that would be
called due diligence it is the
president's sworn duty and by the way
also faithfully executing the laws
finding out oh did they interfere that's
good for America to know so we can
prevent it in the future what Democrats
cared about foreign election
interference they don't and if they were
actually on a fact-finding mission they
wouldn't have invited three known anti
Trump left-wing ivory tower lunatics to
give their biased opinions the Judiciary
Committee's ranking member congressman
Doug Collins he summed it up perfectly
he was on his game today he should have
been announced as the next senator from
Georgia he wasn't thanks governor Kemp
chairman said he just a second ago goes
worse
the elections next year we're scared of
the elections that we'll lose again so
we've got to do this now the clock in
the calendar what's driving impeachment
not the facts - in some ways insinuate
on a live mic with a lot of people
listening that the founding fathers
would have found president Trump guilty
is just simply malpractice in this with
these facts perforce that is just simply
pandering to a camera that is simply
just not right this is not an
impeachment this is just a simple
railroad job in today's is a waste of
time because this is where we're at so I
close today with this it didn't start
with malware it didn't start with a
phone call you know where this started
it started with tears in Brooklyn in
November 2016 great point because of
these very real facts and the complete
lack there's no direct evidence no
testimony constitutional scholar
Jonathan Turley who is no supporter of
President Trump made clear he didn't
vote for presidents from he made the
clear and compelling argument against
the Democrats sham impeachment coup
attempt take a look I'm not a supporter
a president Trump I voted against him my
personal views a president Trump are as
a relevant to my impeachment testimony
as they should be to your impeachment
vote this would be the first impeachment
in history where there would be
considerable debate in my view not
compelling evidence of the commission of
a crime second is the abbreviated period
of this investigation which is
problematic and puzzling this is a
facially incomplete and inadequate
record in order to impeach a president
Jonathan Turley is very calm logical way
he took a sledgehammer to the left
phony narrative and in one of the most
powerful moments of the hearing Turley
flipped the script on the House
Democrats I'm sure they didn't like this
moment take a look President Trump has
gone to Congress ooh to the courts he's
allowed to do that we have three
branches not two I can't emphasize this
enough and I'll say it just one more
time
if you impeach a president if you make a
high crime and misdemeanor out of going
to the courts it isn't abuse of power
it's your abuse of power you are doing
precisely what you're criticizing the
president for doing we have a third
branch that deals with conflicts of the
other two branches and what comes out of
there and what you do with it is the
very definition of legitimacy the first
phase of the Democrats impeachment coup
attempt the ship showed a disaster today
even a bigger disaster and it's clear
that the nutty Nadler circus won't be
any better it's worse Jordan